Benjamin Payne: So first I don’t—this
gentleman and the folks at Hillsdale College
don’t ask for much recognition but I don’t
want to… I can’t stress enough the integral
role that they played in the success of the
school, the support of the students, the support
of the faculty and the support of the school’s
mission and vision. So for a few more words—he’s
a much better speaker than I—Dr. Larry P.
Arnn, the President of Hillsdale College.
Larry P. Arnn: Thank you all for coming here
and for being what you are. I can say on behalf
of the college that I am proud to be here with
you. I’m proud to be here with Ben and with
Roger. Ah, talking into the wrong microphone.
If you didn’t hear that it wasn’t very
good. Ben Payne is an inspiring man and Roger,
who’s about to retire from the chairmanship
of the board—I think now is the right time for
us all to say “Boooooo”. You should know
that the arrangement the college has
with this school is that five cents or never
as much as that will ever come from this school
to Hillsdale College. Why would we do that?
We helped to train the teachers and we know
something about the curriculum and we want
to be of support. We have sent our precious
Kayla Cash, a recent graduate, down here to
work in the school and you’ll find that
she’s an inspiring young woman and not so
great as her mother. But why? There’s going
to be beauty here. And the students are going
to learn that the expression “beauty”
means the highest form of the term good and
they’re going to learn what that is. They’re
going to look at the old books that first
talked about that—a chance to go back to
the beginning when human beings began to figure
this out. They’re going to learn that they
are something and that that something, when
is excellent, practices those virtues that
they wear on their backs. And you mothers
and grandmothers and aunts and uncles—you
should know that one of those virtues is courage
and courage is a hard virtue. It demands that
you do difficult things like the difficult
thing that you do in taking on the raising
of these young people. There’s a sacrifice
in that and a commitment in that that makes
life harder and more complicated. And there
are reasons you do that. And those are the
best reasons in human soul. A lot of you live
in difficult circumstances, I know. And I
know that you worked to overcome those. And
the sign of that is these young people that
are here. And these young people are going
to grow up in those circumstances, and yet
every one of them is fully a human being,
fully capable of living a human life. The
greatest public man that I know attended school
right in there and he was just like one of
these kids. He was smart, he was young, he
didn’t know anything, and what’s happened
to him? He sits on the Supreme Court of the
United States. And how does he do that? I
have a privilege in having known him before
he became a famous man. He is a good man.
He tries so hard to do the right thing and
that has carried him so far. Every one of
these young people is capable of living as
well as that man lives. And they have a right
to the chance. I’ll tell you one little
story about Ben Payne and then I’ll shut
up. I came down and walked around this school
for a day and it is true they don’t know
how to organize events here. So they think
when somebody from out of town comes in, they
have to take him to a fancy restaurant. And
I said to Payne over there. I said “Are
you not serving lunch in this school today?”
And he said “Well, we are. Hot dogs.”
They were pretty good. And I said, “Well,
this is the place to have lunch. This is actually
where we ought to be having lunch today.”
But they still haven’t learned what they
need to know, right? And they—and I sat
with the students and I watched him talk with
them. And I talked with them myself. And he’s
just a... I said to him once. I said, “So
most of these kids grow up with uncertainty
and trouble, right?” And he said, “Yeah.”
And I said, “And that’s got to be made
up for with their families. Can this be done?”
And Ben looked at me and said “Well, Dr.
Arnn. We’re here. What are we going to do?”
Right? And the answer is, just like everybody
standing here today with a threatening rain,
we’re going to do everything we can and
we are going to do the right thing. I ask
you to help with that. It’s going to be
exhausting. It is hard to learn if you really
learn. You know, these kids are going to study
Latin and that’s not easy. And yet when
they learn it—and they can all learn it,
and nearly all of them will—they are going
to be different people when they have mastered
that. They are going to be more fully human
with every passing day. There’s a world
of blessings open to them. All it takes is
some work. I thank you for doing that work
and I want you to understand how honored we
are to be able to help with it. Thanks.